if you start out a side project aiming
it needs to make money you will make
decisions on a complete different level
I think the beauty of a side project is
that you are so playful and experimental
because you don't put the money
component on it you don't put a layer of
money on top of it so I started my blog
as my personal visual archive of things
I find online that interest me and
inspire me it was completely meant just
to be my personal archive and then
slowly but surely I realized because I
started looking at my stats I was like
oh my god this is not so personal
anymore and eventually I realized oh my
god this is a growing community this is
people coming back every day and then
with that all of a sudden you get
companies to come to you and ask you hey
hey can you put my product up here hey
can advertise and again this was not
meant to be a business so when all of a
sudden the aspect of money comes at me I
had to really do some thinking like do I
want that is this is am I going to hurt
my credibility by putting ads on here
but then the interesting thing was when
I was approached by Jim kadhal and he
told me the concept of the deck network
it totally resonated with what I wanted
it to be like for example the deck
network is a teeny tiny ed that is on
the top left side of my blog that
rotates like an RSS feed that just
rotates in and out and it believes in
the concept of you can only have ads
they are really catered to your audience
so the creative audience so it's not
noise but it's actually irrelevant so I
realized oh wait a second I could
actually have advertising on my side
that is actually valuable to my readers
because it points out maybe tools they
would love to use there is a way that
you can add value with advertising if
you have a site or whatever it is that
somebody wants to give you money for in
exchange for eyeballs just make sure
that it adds value to whoever is reading
your site that it is something that you
completely stand behind I will never
ever write about something if I don't
love it
and unfortunately there's too many sites
that that just say well but we have to
bring the bacon home so we just going to
take this advertising and I think that's
where you ruin it that's where you lose
the trust of your readers your audience
and there is nothing that I value more
than the trust of the people that come
back to my site every day your
credibility is all you have and I think
it doesn't have to do anything whether
you run a blog or not it's in your day
today I don't lose your credibility
don't sell out